le bally's à nice mais l'induction de
solomonoff sont d épistémologie c'est à
dire des façons de transformer des
données en savoir plus tôt d'une
meilleure description possible de notre
savoir et de notre ignorance
sachons ces données on a vu dans les
épisodes précédents et en particulier
dans l'épisode 36 que c'est
épistémologie avait des propriétés
absolument remarquable est
essentiellement unique et encore je ne
vous ai pas parlé du théorème
d'admissibilité du théorème de la classe
complète du théorème du livre de contes
néerlandais ou du théorème de james cox
bref ces propriétés ont amené le
génialissime rei solomonoff à conclure
que le bail à nice mme ça marche et
surtout que au final c'est bien ça qui
compte
à en croire les épisodes précédents pour
savoir il faut il suffit d'appliquer les
lois des probabilités et en particulier
la formule du savoir ok mais à quoi bon
de savoir à quoi ça peut servir de
dépenser autant de tant d'attention et
d'énergie à mieux comprendre l'étendue
de notre connaissance et de notre
ignorance
quelle est la valeur de ce travail
épistémique alors je dois bien dire que
à titre personnel j'attribue énormément
de valeur en soi à mieux estimer mes
connaissances et mon ignorance
il ya quelque chose d'incroyablement
satisfaisant à mes yeux à me rendre
compte des erreurs du lait du passé ou
pas pour me moquer de lui mais parce que
je sens alors que je progresse
épistémique mans et je ressens même
quelque chose de jouissif dans le fait
de réussir à me méfier des pulsions de
mon intuition ou de mon raisonnement
motivé et a effectué au lieu de cela un
raisonnement aussi proche que possible
de celui recommandé par des génies comme
david frum père simon laplace la place
et rei solomonoff mais même à mes yeux
ce n'est pas là la plus grande valeur du
raisonnement bayésiens notamment lorsque
l'incertitude est grande comme ça a été
le cas au hasard au cours de l'année
2020 et comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
raisonner avec les lois des probabilités
c'est surtout critique pour prendre de
meilleures décisions
justement en 2000 il ya donc 20 ans
l'informaticien markus ritter a eu la
brillante idée de combiner l'induction
de solomonoff la théorie de la prise de
décisions pour formaliser un algorithme
de prise de décisions optimales en
présence d' incertitudes l'algorithme
ainsi conçu par peter fut nommé à xi
pour artificial intelligence cross tweed
in d'auxonne
depuis cet algorithme est souvent décrit
comme la forme ultime d'intelligence
pour comprendre haïti il
falloir d'abord posé un cadre
d'applications qui est le cadre très
général de l'apprentissage par
renforcement à chaque instant
l'algorithme acsi doit prendre une
décision en choisissant une action parmi
un ensemble fini à d'actions
potentielles en pratique pour les
algorithmes d'aujourd'hui ceux ci
corresponde à un message envoyé que ce
soit une recommandation de vidéos la
publication d'un texte générés par
l'algorithme ou un signal qui dit de
tourner le volant d'une voiture après
avoir entrepris l'action en question
l'algorithme maxi reçoit ensuite des
données observationnelles que lui
permettront d'affiner sa compréhension
du monde comme dans le cadre de
solomonoff on va supposer que ces
données sont numérisés ainsi à chaque
instant d'observation appartient à un
ensemble fini au d'observation possible
à cet instant qui va correspondre
typiquement un ensemble de données que
peut recevoir l'algorithme comme la
dernière vidéo mise en ligne par flos
copie le dernier tweet de jules haag et
leffe ou le signal envoyé par le capteur
l'ida de la voiture en plus de ces
données observationnelles d'algorithmics
y va aussi recevoir une récompense air
qui peut par exemple correspondre au
nombre de vue d'une vidéo où nombre de
like they do 28 ou au feedback et d'un
humain qui dit aac si si l'algorithme à
xi a fait quelque chose de bien
ou quelque chose de dangereux dans le
cas de jeu comme les échecs ou legault
cette récompense air d'un terrien qu'à
la fin de la partie est typiquement égal
à 1 6i à gagner et à moins-16 non noté
que ce cadre est extrêmement général on
peut exprimer le problème de la
recommandation de vidéo par youtube ou
celui de la conception d'un chat bottes
censé être bienveillant dans ce cas
alors on peut également formulé
l'expérience de vie des humains dans ce
cadre où les actions sont souvent ce
qu'on va dire où les mouvements qu'on va
demander à nos muscles de faire les
observations sont les signaux envoyés
par nos différents sens comme la vue
l'ouïe et l'odorat et où les récompenses
sont entre autres les décharges de
dopamine relâché par notre cerveau enfin
on peut aussi décrire le fonctionnement
des entreprises des partis politiques et
de nombreuses associations comme étant
un problème d'apprentissage pas
renforcement toutes ces organisations
prennent des décisions par exemple sur
les positions publiques qu'elles vont
prendre observe le monde notamment en
lisant des articles sur internet et
reçoivent des espèces de récompense si
leurs profits augmentent si leur
influence politique grandit ou si leur
cause avance en particulier faire du
bien dans le monde peut aussi
parfaitement s'exprimer dans le cadre de
l'apprentissage par renforcement en
supposant que les récompenses reçues
seront d'autant plus grandes que le
monde va mieux si telle
car on dit que les récompenses sont
alors aligné et on reviendra plus tard
dans cette vidéo sur cette nation
l'algorithme haïti est alors conçu pour
résoudre le problème de l'apprentissage
pas renforcement plus précisément haïti
est conçu pour maximiser les récompenses
qui seront reçus et intuitivement pour
cela l'algorithme active à appliquer les
calculs de l'induction de solomonoff
puis inférées les lois et les états
probable de son environnement
puis l'algorithme va imaginer les
conséquences probables des différentes
actions qui pourraient entreprendre
enfin l'algorithme va choisir de prendre
la décision qui maximise les récompenses
reçues
alors en fait ce ne sont pas les
récompenses reçues que l'algorithme maxi
maximise il ya quelques subtilités qu'il
est utile de garder en tête pour
comprendre le fonctionnement daksi et en
particulier pour mieux anticiper le type
de décision que l'algorithme maxi peut
prendre le premier point est que
l'algorithme xxi maximis uniquement la
récompense futur après tout les
récompenses passé elles ont déjà été
reçues et rex il ne peut plus rien y
faire alors pourra se dire que ces
récompenses passé pourrait être amenée à
être corrigé dans le futur mais alors ce
qui intéresse
alexis ce ne sont pas les récompenses
passé reçu ce qui intéressera alexis
davantage dans ce cas ce sont les
corrections futur des récompenses passé
que l'algorithme subira et ça ça revient
bien à part les deux récompenses futur
pas du passé en particulier ça ça veut
dire que ce n'est pas parce que
l'algorithme à xi a reçu la récompense
maximale dans le passé que l'algorithme
va s'en satisfaire
accès est programmé pour maximiser les
récompenses futur
il n'y a pas de phénomène temporal de
compensation qui est programmée dans
alexis l'algorithme axes y va alors
constamment regarder prospectivement
vers le futur
mais bien entendu et de façon cruciale
l'algorithme à xxi ne connaît pas sa
récompense futur cet algorithme a
nécessairement une incertitude
épistémique vis-à-vis des récompenses
futur du coup il est techniquement
erroné de dire qu'à xxi maximise ses
récompenses futur ce que cet algorithme
maximise ça va être en fait l'expérience
de ces récompenses futur c'est à dire la
moyenne des récompenses qu'elle recevra
dans tous les scénarios futurs qu'elle
envisage pondérée par les probabilités
de ces différents futurs
on a toutefois alors un dernier problème
à régler techniquement la somme de
toutes les récompenses futur espérer
pourrait être infinie notamment si
l'algorithme maxxi n'est pas conçu avec
un horizon futur limites mais surtout
n'est pas clair que le futur dans un
milliard de milliards de milliards de
siècle est vraiment aussi important que
le futur dans un an
en tout cas pour la plupart de nous
autres humains ou plus précisément n'est
pas clair que ce qui se passera entre 1
milliard et 2 milliards de siècle dont
le futur soit un milliard de fois plus
important que ce qui se passera dans le
siècle à venir la solution la plus
courante pour modéliser cela consiste à
introduire un facteur d ce compte qui va
typiquement dire que ce qu'il se passera
entre 2051 et 2052 et peut-être dix ont
deux fois moins important que ce qu'il
se passera en 2021
si c'est le cas on dira que l'on a
un temps caractéristiques des ce conte
de l'or autour de 30 ans et ça ça
impliquera que ce qu'il se passera dans
un siècle est dix fois moins importante
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
alors bien sûr on a toutefois des
désaccords entre nous sur quel est le
temps caractéristiques des comptes
adéquat à considérer ceux qui ont une
vision plus court-termiste diront
peut-être que ce temps des comptes est
de l'ordre de 12 ans peut-être alors que
des visions plus long termiste
défendront détendent escompte de l'ordre
du millénaire voire peut-être de l'ordre
du milliard de milliards de milliards de
milliards de siècle ou quelque chose
comme ça en fait on peut même envisager
le fait que chacun d'entre nous un temps
d'escompté différents pour des
considérations différentes typiquement
je trouve ça important que le monde
aille encore bien dans un siècle mais
j'ai tendance à trouver ça important
également que j'ai de quoi manger dans
les 24 heures à venir
quoi qu'il en soit l'algorithme haïti
est généralement conceptualiser avec un
temps des comptes donnés dès lors à tout
moment maxime maximisera l'espérance de
la somme des récompenses futurs
escomptés
or en fait plus précisément
que l'algorithme active à maximiser
c'est une suite de décisions à prendre
qui peuvent réagir à des données futurs
pourraient être ainsi parlé d'
optimisation de stratégie mais dans le
jargon on parle plutôt d'optimisation de
politiques policiers en anglais ce qui
est intéressant de voir c'est qu'une
politique n'est pas un plan prédéterminé
au sens du formalisme taxi une politique
peut très bien être de la forme alors on
va tester un peu ceux ci et si ça a
l'air de marcher on investira encore
plus dans les tests et si vraiment ça
marche alors on va redéployer sa à
grande échelle comme on en a parlé
d'ailleurs dans les épisodes sur les
essais adaptatifs appliquées notamment
aux tests cliniques des traitements
contre 8,19 un autre aspect important
est de noter que le choix de la
politique à adopter par alexis résulte
d'un calcul contrat factuel
autrement dit l'algorithme maxi va
imaginer l'adoption d'une politique et
calculer l'espérance de récompenses
futurs escomptés qui en résulte elle va
ensuite imaginé l'adoption d'une autre
politique est calculé à nouveau
l'espérance de récompenses futurs
escomptés qui s'ensuit elle va ensuite
continuer ses calculs avec toutes sortes
de politiques en fait l'algorithme à xi
va considérer l'ensemble de toutes les
politiques calculable alexis maximise
ainsi contrat actuellement le choix de
la politique à adopter
enfin une dernière remarque à faire et
que la décision de l'algorithme ike ci
correspond simplement à des messages
envoyés
et alors on pourrait croire que envoyé
un message à travers internet ça doit
pas être si l'ange re imaginez un
algorithme haïti par exemple qu'ils
enverraient des milliards de messages
par seconde
si ce n'est beaucoup plus en
personnalisant chacun de ces messages à
chacun des humains cible l'algorithme
aqsiq pourrait influencer
quotidiennement des milliards d'humains
les amener ainsi petit à petit a
davantage croire x ou à davantage faire
y
à l'instar d'un sobre et dit un tel
rythme pour être ainsi manipuler les
cours de la bourse et se faire
énormément d'argent
il pourrait aussi découvrir des secrets
de dirigeants influents payer des
salariés faire du lobbying voire menacer
des individus
finalement un peu comme le font déjà
certaines grandes organisations
intel algorithmes serait alors
extrêmement dangereux mais bon je ne
vais pas affirmer que des algorithmes
capables d'envoyer des messages des
milliards d'humains ça existe déjà
du coup je vais simplement vivement le
suggérer
alors il existe tout
taxi et en particulier de cette
maximisation contrat factuel en
particulier il ya quelques mois un
article sur le paradoxe de newcombe paix
tant que ce paradoxe révèle une faille
dans la conception taxi et cet article
c'est moi qui ai écrit alors je ne vais
pas rentrer dans trop de détails c'est
un mériterait une vidéo à part entière
mais en bref l'argument de cet article
c'est que le formalisme d'haïti échoue
anticipé la capacité d'entités
extérieures à alexis à prédire ce cas ci
fera ou plus précisément par conception
axis restreint un ensemble de théories
trop restreint est en gros ça ça ouvre
la porte à une dévastatrice diagonale de
kantor et plus précisément à des cas où
il est impossible de faire de la
maximisation contractuels bref à en
croire cet article ou sélection de
vidéos de monsieur fille
le problème de prise de décision ça
semble en fait encore plus complexe que
ce qu'on pourrait croire
il reste toutefois un aspect important
de la conception taxi a précisé à savoir
quels sont ces récompenses qui motive
ses prises de décision comment sont
calculées les récompenses taxi et
surtout qu'est ce que ces récompenses
vont impliquer sur la décision effective
prise par ike 6 et bien selon beaucoup
en particulier selon les deux auteurs du
livre le fabuleux chantier cette
question est au coeur de l'éthique des
algorithmes et de l'information et il
est donc urgent de davantage
l'investissement en particulier d'après
ce livre il semble urgent dès à présent
de faire en sorte que les récompenses de
tout algorithmes d'apprentissage déployé
à très grande échelle soit aligné autant
que possible avec ce que nous autres
humains voudrions vraiment maximiser si
nous réfléchissions davantage et si nous
informions davantage sur nos préférences
sur ce qui est désirable et sur comment
y parvenir
quel est le problème dit de l'alignement
des algorithmes et à titre personnel je
pense qu'il est urgent qu'on trouve des
solutions pour le résoudre de manière
robuste il me semble plus important que
jamais que des algorithmes ne déployait
à très grande échelle sache ce que
l'ensemble de l'humanité désir aura
vraiment au plus profond d'elle-même et
que ses algorithmes aide l'humanité à
atteindre ses objectifs
alors malheureusement concevoir un tel
algorithmes n'est absolument pas il
s'agit là d'un énorme chantier
et pour finir cette vidéo j'aimerais
insister surtout sur le fait qu'il
s'agisse d'un fabuleux chantier un
fabuleux chantier il est devenu urgent
d' accomplir